nazar is the owner of the restorer in
ukraine
he specializes in repairing and
restoring furniture with damage and
effects
this is a wood veneer table with an oak
base
the owner forgot to blow out a candle
and it burned through the veneered
surface
into the wood this left a 30 centimeter
wide hole
that's about 3 to 4 millimeters deep
before he can start any restoration work
he cleans and removes as much of the
burned area as possible
he uses a small grinder to remove the
blackened layers
then he uses a blade to carefully remove
larger pieces
after a basic cleaning and decreasing he
adds clear packaging tape over the
entire area
and trims around it this leaves only the
damaged area
exposed and the other areas protected by
the tape
then it's time to repair the hole
to do this he's using a wood putty this
acts as a filler
and hardener and can easily be covered
with toners
paints and varnish which you'll use
later on in the process
after drying for about 40 minutes the
putty hardens and he can sand it to
create a level surface
he uses a cloth with a light solvent to
clean the dust off before moving on to
the next step
after that the tape comes off
to start adding color back into the
repaired hole he uses a mix of tints
and furniture wax that he's color
matched to the original wood tone
he starts around the perimeter and works
his way into the center
he's doing this using a nozzle and gas
soldering iron
this melts the wax onto the damaged area
the wax helps to restore and fill the
color of the wood veneer
he finishes this repair by leveling the
surface with an abrasive restoration
fiber once the burns are removed and the
hole is filled
it's time to add the wood grain nazar
does this by painting it with a tinted
alcohol-based toner
he paints it in by hand and uses a
semi-matte varnish to lock everything
in and keep it protected from dirt and
water in the future
you